سيفعل الرياضيون المحترفون
أي شيء تقريبًا للحصول على ميزة ،
ولسوء الحظ بالنسبة للبعض ، يعني ذلك
الغش من عقاقير تحسين الأداء
إلى المراقبة بالفيديو إلى القمار ،
فهذه هي بعض من أشهر
فضائح الغش الرياضي التي لم
يستقر الغبار بعد على مخطط سرقة اللافتات
التي تتضمن  اثنان من
الفائزين في بطولة العالم للبيسبول ، هيوستن أستروس ،
يستخدمان التكنولوجيا بشكل غير قانوني لفك رموز
إشارات الفرق المتعارضة وفقًا
لنتائج الدوري الرسمية ، ونتيجة لذلك
، تم
طرد فريق بوسطن ريد سوكس من فريق الإدارة العليا في هيوستن ،
وقد أقتبس الآن مدير الفريق أليكس كورا
اتفاقًا متبادلًا.  للانفصال بعد أن
أطلق الدوري على كورا كواحد من
المسؤولين عن الانتهاكات التي
ارتكبها صاحب العمل السابق لأستروس كورا خلال
صواريخ باتريوتس التي تورطوا في العديد من
الفضائح على مدار السنوات التي تم القبض عليهم فيها وهم
يصورون إشارات اليد أثناء مباراة
ضد نيويورك جيتس في عام 2007  التي
أصبحت تعرف باسم بوابة التجسس بعد ثماني
سنوات جاءت إلى بوابة اتحاد كرة القدم الأميركي  وجد
أن 11 من كرات اللعبة الـ 12 التي
قدمها الفريق لمباراة بطولة الاتحاد الآسيوي 2015
كانت مبالغًا فيها مما قد
يسهل السيطرة
على لاعب الوسط توم برادي بتعليق أربع مباريات
وتم تغريم باتريوتس
مليون دولار ومصادرة مسودة.
اللقطات
بعد سنوات من الإنكار اعترف راكب الدراجة لانس
أرمسترونج في النهاية بأنه
خدع في طريقه إلى سبعة
ألقاب في سباق فرنسا للدراجات ، زعمت وكالة مكافحة المنشطات الأمريكية
أن أرمسترونج كان في
قلب برنامج المنشطات الأكثر تطوراً
واحترافًا وناجحًا
الذي شهدته الرياضة على الإطلاق و
تم تجريد تداعيات أرمسترونج من
ألقابه وتم حظره بسبب
ركوب الدراجات الاحترافي مدى الحياة ، ستصبح فضيحة بلاك سوكس عام 1919
واحدة من
أكثر حالات الغش شهرة في
تاريخ الرياضة ، حيث تغلب سينسيناتي ريدز
على شيكاغو وايت سوكس المفضل بشدة
في  بطولة العالم بعد
ما يقرب من عام تم اتهام ثمانية أعضاء من
White Sox بالتآمر
مع المقامرين ليخسروا عن قصد
على الرغم من تبرئتك في المحاكمة في عام
1921 ، تم منع اللاعبين من
ممارسة لعبة البيسبول مدى الحياة من قبل المفوض
كينيساو ماونتن لاندي.